i think music is a very strong force on
all children i think children are very
open
to the important things and music gets
in in a big way
i think again i'm very lucky that my
music attracts such nice people
[Music]
[Music]
when you're teenaged you have songs that
go with every relationship
it's an important thing i think when you
make an album you're making it for the
people that listen to it and essentially
for yourself hoping that when it's at a
point where you find it interesting
other people will as well
[Music]
everyone finds an obsession they just
become fanatical about it
and music was the thing
that for me
gave me a great sense of reward to
actually be able to create
something out of nothing
and you actually
form a relationship with the thing that
you become obsessed with
and to the point of where it's very dear
to you and when i was very young music
was all always around in my house it was
always been played particularly
traditional music english and irish
and they're very strong influences in my
music now
[Music]
i think um
confidence when you're performing is
something that
you learn
to bluff hopefully you look confident
but i don't know if you ever truly are
confident of yourself or what you do
and in a way i think that's probably
what keeps an awful lot of artists going
the insecurity of themselves and their
work and
and the hope that by doing the next
piece
they can prove to themselves that they
can still do it
[Music]
the song cloud busting was
inspired by a book
called a book of dreams
and
really the video had to do justice
to the book
as the song had to do justice to it and
it was trying to depict
that wonderful relationship between the
father and the son
[Music]
donald sutherland is an incredible actor
very sensitive he has a very great face
that also has a sense of
sadness and
beauty in there
and i think donald
was interested in the story it's an
incredible story it's very moving
and a lot of people
find it incredibly sad and beautiful
and he was absolutely perfect
and we were very very lucky that he was
able to be involved and had the time to
do it
[Music]
i think dance and music are in their
absolute essence sensuality they're
about emotion and expression and i think
that
in a way
all life has something very sensual
about it it gives me everything and
takes an awful lot out of me
it's the thing i do
[Music]